[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
know where we are
[Music]
icarus
evening ladies
watch out
who is this
[Music]
good okay everyone that was good
we could do 10 better that was beautiful
very very good because they're really so
good
how my friends from college are here
perfect timing welcome to the set of
chandar dastani icarus
i'm playing you you like the costume we
need to talk tell the director i have
some notes we need to talk to you in
private
oh karon he's worked with me for 50
years i trust him completely
actually when we first met he thought i
was a vampire and he tried to stake me
through the heart i've apologized so
many times not quite enough times very
close though i'll let you know oh i have
to get ready for the next scene come to
my tent we'll talk there you can you
guys are gonna love the next scene i
come in on a wire because you know i
can't fly wait are we getting back
together we need to talk the deviants
are back we don't know how many there
are
you need to come with us
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here seven thousand years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout
[Music]
we were history not to interfere in any
human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
something's happening to us
[Music]
we need to find the others i haven't
seen some of them for centuries
you hear that sprite family reunion it's
about time
it's a really interesting mix having 10
characters we're a big slightly
dysfunctional family this is what the
end of the world looks like at least we
have front row seats well you know
what's never saved the planet you're
sarcasm
cersei she has the power to manipulate
mata and she's had a long-running on-off
relationship with icarus how long were
you together 5 000 years i guess you can
call that long term
icarus is the loyal soldier dad that's
superman with the cape and you're
shooting laser beams out of your eyes
i don't wear a cape
fastest can assemble anything out of any
kind of technology there were more
deviants than you said well i'm sure
there was one for you it was
athena she's the goddess of war
she can manifest different weapons
which was very fun
gilgamesh
he's a protector
his specialty is a strong punch
this is makari none of us has seen him
for centuries
sprite can create illusions
she's really sarcastic especially with
kingo
i would say kingo is
a little self-involved bingo didn't
beaster i've directed some things too
droog he's mind control he stands up for
what he believes in and that there
shouldn't be violence
don't we don't interfere in their wars
and then there is ajax she's kind of the
leader of the eternals her power is
healing
this planet and these people
have changed me
these superheroes
reflect the world we live in
everybody is unique and special
i think eternals is the most epic movie
that marvel has done and i really really
mean that
they're really gonna see a movie
unlike any they've ever seen before
[Music]
[Music]
you